definitely like you're on a super hot
topic how i like to think about content
is it's great to build an audience but
it's better if i if you understand the
business model to hey let's get an
audience where you can then convert to
the thing that you're trying to sell
right personal brand is easier to scale
and when i grow up i want to be like
heaven
here we go hi what's happening here
george is a part of my movement makers
program uh and as part of that we're
doing this ig life together too so
welcome aboard man how can i help what's
on your mind
first of all thank you very much for the
opportunity to meet you uh i actually
got to see you live i was at an eddie
panero event in miami in 2019 i got to
see him in person i said you know what
someday i would love to work with evan
here we are thank you very much evan i
love it man so
he thinks i would tell you first and
foremost i uh i'm not an ig guy this is
my first instagram that's why i had
tools i didn't even know um i'm on
youtube i have 26 000 subscribers there
big fan of all your work throughout the
years and uh quite frankly um i'm in the
blockchain space and i generally what i
do is blockchain bitcoin and crypto and
uh i am i'm an instructor i have over
160 000 students worldwide in blockchain
bitcoin crypto and i want to expand my
impact by being more active being able
to create more content like you being
more open being able to share um among
my channels at 26 000 subscribers i
would love to someday be like you right
so that's exactly what i want to talk
about how do i expand my impact
worldwide i love it let's go man uh what
are you selling let's start with that
are you selling training courses
coaching
yes i have a series of courses i have a
series of certifications also so a
perfect example would be like my courses
include blockchain and bitcoin
fundamentals cryptocurrency fundamentals
metaverse fundamentals nft fundamentals
right and then there's advanced level
courses how to create your own metaverse
programmers developers right so there's
a whole series of courses and then
there's certifications that i sell for
people that take multiple courses then
they take a certification these are
internationally credentialed and that's
what we offer right so the key goal is
what i want is to be able to share more
of the content like i do i publish on a
weekly basis i publish brand new videos
and it's cost like what is bitcoin why
is blockchain the future you know what
is cryptocurrency things like that is
how i share but then the goal is to
bring people on board into this universe
called blockchain institute of
technology where we can help people
learn how to move this whole blockchain
movement forward that's really what i
believe in got it i love i love the
energy i love the excitement you can
tell you're really into this stuff which
is awesome i i even got my lava lamps
which by the way are part when people
think about cryptocurrency it's the
cryptography and crypto lava lamps are a
key component of cryptography many
people don't know that
okay i love it how much do you like
covering
the news and what's going on right now
uh i i have not done as much as i could
mostly because there's so much
volatility and a lot of the content that
i've been focusing on is teaching
something as opposed to saying this is
what's happening in the world as opposed
to taking a position on things like for
example something huge that's happening
is ethereum is moving to proof of stake
in my world that's a massive thing i
haven't really die i haven't really
focused on that because i'm teaching
people how to create new
cryptocurrencies and right so it's it's
a choice i really don't talk a lot about
news
so you know is what you're doing now
it's like how do we have a bigger impact
the question is more like how much do
you enjoy covering that stuff
and having an
opinion well here here's the thing
i
the challenge with opinions that i've
always had is that in opinions sometimes
always someone's on the other side of
the opinion right so i personally i'm
not a big fan of what's going on with
proof of stake with ethereum and uh i'm
like i think it's something that really
hurts against the whole concept of
decentralization i never thought
ethereum could just switch like that
from one to the other one and screw an
entire industry of ethereum miners but
that's a personal opinion in the process
i'll piss off a lot of people if i
position that now the question is is
that necessarily a bad thing and that's
the key goal
when you take a position some people say
you're on that side you're not on this
side therefore i don't talk to you
anymore right and listen that's part of
being an expert you know like in you
teaching and training things it's it's
you could have
just reported the news and sharing a
little bit without pissing people off
you know like the
uh what news anchors maybe used to be
like reporting on what's happening and
even
taking it as a
as an example of what
people should learn and know so you know
el salvador being on bitcoin pros and
cons how's it happening for them an
entire country moving there look this is
the future of where bitcoin is going
even if it's not working out so well for
them right now right you know this is
still the future if and there's still a
lot of good highlights going on it's
just people don't see those highlights
there's a lot of good stuff going on
well right so that could be that could
be you
yeah that's a good point that's a great
point and the people aren't seeing
anymore you could be the guy here's
george telling people so it doesn't have
to be pissing people off it's definitely
a brain
if i made videos talking about the top
10 stupidest things kanye west has said
that video would blow up but i don't
want to make that video it's not part of
my brain right now some people i still
hate on my videos some people will will
you know even if it's all positive
you'll still always have somebody who
doesn't like the thing that you're doing
right for sure as long as the intention
going in isn't to piss people off you
could talk about ethereum moving to
uh to their you know eth2 everything and
your your take on it pros and cons
without you can still acknowledge what
other people like hey this is actually
screwing people over who have who are
ethereal miners and now they don't have
a business anymore that really sucks
right and i still think it's like good
for where the industry is going like you
can recognize the other side without
saying that's cool you could have it's
just all the intent and how you bring it
up sure you still might piss some people
off but if you said
and all you losers who are eath mining
you guys come when you knew this was
coming right like it's a completely
different approach yeah yeah that's cool
so there's so much education that needs
to happen in this space most people
still don't know what it is
you see ethereum walking on the street
nobody like most people 98 of people
have no idea what it is
so there's definitely like you're on a
super hot topic right right how i like
to think about content is it's great to
build an audience but it's better if i
if you understand the business model to
hey let's get an audience where you can
then convert to the thing that you're
trying to sell right so if you're if
you're trying to sell
teaching certification education then
it's great for you to make your videos
once a week
what i'd love to see you do is add in
some coaching videos
um so you take something like literally
human beings like what you're doing
right now with me this is it yeah
exactly this is it
i've never done that and and the fact is
i do calls on that i just never have
actually turned it into part of the
teaching curriculum
well that's an interesting take it's uh
you might be able to do double duty like
your current calls maybe you can record
them and that becomes content for the
channel or it's something new that
you're bringing in but it becomes part
of the marketing in that
you take all the different things that
you're doing you're fortunate enough to
now actually have a you're not just
starting up and have no students and
trying to figure out how to get this
thing off the ground right you have
people been through
various levels of your programs all the
way up to certification is like the
highest level of what you would sell
right
right yes absolutely so you can take
some how many people have gone through
the certification
well let's put things in context there's
different certifications so there's some
certification there's hundreds of people
there's some certifications have
thousands of people right now they also
vary depending on on price points right
so i mean and we got to say i got people
that are certified from world bank ernst
and young centra uh central bank of
curacao fannie mae so i have huge
companies but many of the people are
just everyday people that just really
like they really wanted to get into
blockchain and they want to get into
blockchain space and they want to learn
how can i apply to these jobs well you
take these courses and you can apply for
these jobs which is a great opportunity
and how much one-on-one are you doing
with these people it depends on the
certification level so uh what i have i
have a community for example there's a
facebook group where they're able to
interact between them and then depending
on the certification there's a certain
number of one-on-ones that we do and of
course they have any questions that we
do some one-on-ones now mind you i'm not
against it the question is would that be
a scalable approach because right now
you're able to give me a little bit of
your time but your time is really really
valuable how much one-on-one can you
really give right it's scalable through
content
right so here's the thing i'm saying if
george george is really busy
george doesn't do one-on-ones you can
even stop doing one-on-ones it's just
george's trainers who'll come in and do
an l certification
but to get accurate george is launching
a new show
where he will coach
whatever you're struggling with
you cannot buy 45 minutes of george's
time or or however long you want to be
like this show it's going to be a part
of the show yeah that makes sense here
it is so if you've been through the
certification
and you want 25 minutes with with george
to answer whatever questions you have to
help you take your your training your
learning to the next level do you want
to come on and be with him and some
people will say no
cool and some people will like what i
get time with george this is insane of
course like we're doing right now well
like but we're just like
some people say no and some people say
yes and again that's really ironic
people will go on jerry springer they'll
go on your show right
one thing
while we're here i want to ask you a
different question this is new for me
this is i i don't do instagram because i
haven't done instagram um i've spent
time on my youtube my channel my youtube
channel i'm not where you're at but i'm
at 26 000 subscribers so i think of when
i think of publishing content i think i
got to create content so i can publish
on youtube now i've i've created a new
process to be able to do shorts and i'm
doing five shorts per week something
monday tuesday monday to friday and then
i publish a brand new video full length
on thursdays i have two youtube channels
i have the george levy brand and the
blockchain institute brand
so for instance you had a hard time
today because you didn't know what i'm
talking to george and i was in your
audience but this ig is blockchain
institute it's not really george levy
right so the question is am i doing
myself a disservice by diluting my brand
between both brands that's what i'm
trying to think it's a brand new thing
it's also an effort in time thing a
personal brand is easier to scale
because people love a face people's like
people when you first join i didn't know
who you are i didn't you know but then
like the energy and the excitement and
george cares so much about blockchain
like it's great right
like people want to learn from a
passionate
instructor and if even if it's not that
even if it's not you teaching everything
your team it's like you're the guy at
the top who then recruits the
instructors who are going to teach it so
it's a lot nobody has a ton of
association to a logo typically it's
like you you're the guy
makes sense so it's easy to make it
under undo your brain
but in terms of the content
just to finish the point on on the
certification people coming through who
you're going to do lives with it doesn't
have to be alive like this it could
still be on zoom dude zoom
we've already got a nice looking studio
the other person coming on doesn't have
to everybody is now zoom
capable
we've all been trained
i do zooms all the time this is a new
creature for me but okay i could do zoom
sure do it on zoom and here's what's
gonna happen they're gonna come on and
you're gonna say hey here's susan she
just completed our xyz certification
now we're talking about the
certification without talking about the
certification right it's not it's not a
salesman susan's going to say oh my god
george
your certification was awesome i love
that i learned so much now she's talking
to certification without talking about
certification and then you're going to
help her and the content is super easy
you don't need susan to give you a five
page list of her background and
everything you're gonna show up just
like this i don't know what we're
talking about right you're gonna show
absolutely you know what you're talking
about inside of blockchain and susan's
gonna ask you questions that you already
know how to answer because you've
answered them a thousand times before
and then that creates amazing content
for your channel but it also helps me
learn oh george does certification oh
susan love the certification cool maybe
i should get in on that as well so we're
working with our current customers
and then taking them just a level deeper
but people who already love us and
they're going to say great things about
us because if you just made a video
saying here's my new certification why
you should sign up nobody's going to
watch that video nobody's going to go
and sign up like that video is done on
arrival but if you're making it valuable
but you're bringing people in who love
you and we'll talk about certifications
like you know in module 4 when you said
blank how do i right so we get to
sprinkle you don't even have to prompt
it you don't have to say certification
sure just come up in the conversation um
and so if you had some who've done
hundreds and some that are thousands you
already have a big enough pool to pull
from
but you can then use that same strategy
for any of your products that you offer
the free downloads that you have any of
the guides any of the courses hey here's
here's bill he just completed my course
on
blockchain 101. bill
welcome aboard man like oh my god
blockchain 101 george it was great thank
you for making that course it made it so
easy for me
here's what i'm trying to do and then
you go and help bill and then in the
link you can link up your blockchain 101
course right it's the easiest kind of
content to make
because you don't have the script you
don't have to plan you don't have to
prepare you just show up you just have
to have your assistant book
george and bill and who and susan and
whoever to kind of be on your show which
i saw you have a beautiful system you
have a beautiful beautiful process set
up you actually you know i've been
following you for many many years and i
got to tell you one of the things that i
love most about what you're doing is
that in the process of going through
this with you i'm actually learning a
lot of what you're doing which i have to
say to anybody that still is not part of
this movement you've got to get on this
program so genuinely and i can see how
these can be a valuable marketing
vehicle because you got people like me
who are passionate about your work
telling everybody in the audience how
amazing this is right like at the
beginning there is george she's part of
my movement makers program and when i
grow up i want to be like heaven
[Laughter]
but you don't have to do it on ig you
know definitely you just do inside zoom
but it becomes youtube content and then
the best moments from that get clipped
for tick tock for youtube shorts for
reals for everything else i would if
your goal is to convert people i would i
would highly recommend you move more
towards long form content than shorts
sure shorts are are great for audience
growth but a lot of the people who watch
shorts don't then go watch long form
content
and they don't go and buy your stuff
interesting so the goal is i want people
to buy my stuff get in my certification
because somebody who's in a short minute
they're like they're scrolling there's
got to be something that pops instantly
they're not in the mindset i'm going to
go watch a 45-minute training session
i'm gonna go get certified on this it's
just a different psychology so it's
great as filler content so if you're
making one video a week then to have six
shorts cool do it but i'd much rather
you go to three or four or five long
form videos and
less shorts because it's going to help
you achieve your business objectives a
lot more
and that's very very valuable because
one of the things the shorts creeper is
brand new to me so for example when i
think about instagram i think of reels
quite frankly i don't know anything
about instagram so there's this thing
called reels there's this new thing
called youtube shorts there's this thing
i don't use tic tac right so like i've
always been on the youtube space and
i've built towards building my channel
right and now i'm seeing all these
different channels and i'm saying okay
so i need to go short from so what
you're telling me is that yes you'll be
able i'll be able to i guess i would be
able to find new subscribers but those
subscribers will not necessarily be the
the die-hard subscribers that go through
my long-form content it's a very low
conversion over to your long-term
content and even more conversion onto
whatever you're selling whatever they're
buying no they just want little quick
tidbits of content yeah quick quick bite
so it's good filler content so what i
would start is long-form content and if
you really want to hack it and just make
it easy to be everywhere
then you take your long-form content if
you're going to talk to somebody for 45
minutes or however long your show is
going to be you're going to have
multiple aha moments and you're going to
drop some bombs and some gems in there
that maybe you've never shared before
but it'll come out as you're talking to
people it's just going to happen
you take that 45 second clip and i i
would keep it the 45 seconds or less
45 seconds or less you cut it and this
can be something in your team but you
cut it to be vertical because all the
all the short from yeah
and then you put that to instagram reels
youtube shorts
tiktok and twitter
the same twitter also because it's under
45 seconds so i could still use twitter
i never thought about that twitter is
the 24 second is the limit the other
ones you can go longer but 45 is the
limit on twitter and for where you are
twitter is important
sure for nft from
like twitter twitter is twitter
super important and so i would
definitely be making twitter content uh
i mean it's good for everybody
when it's easy because if you're making
the same piece of content you're posting
everywhere go for it but especially for
you i would prioritize twitter over
instagram
that's great it's gonna be a lot better
because i do have i do have a twitter
following and i've been building it
throughout the years and that's great i
didn't even consider it because i don't
think of twitter as a video platform the
fact is a 45 second video can fit on
twitter that makes sense groovy that's
perfect evan thank you very very much
for sharing that with me i actually have
a team right now that
is going through all my videos and
clipping it into little shorts little
shorts little shorts but i've told them
to do 60 seconds maybe what i should do
is start thinking about doing some
longer form content and then saying cut
out those little clips from the longer
form content yeah and do it like that
that longer form content i can also do
in a in an individual session with a
student somebody has been certified yep
that's great yeah very valuable so great
great
and also twitter uh again when you're
doing your long-form videos you're going
to have a bunch of one-liners that you
say too
that you could pull out as quotes
like text quotes for your twitter
account and twitter is very forgiving
like you could post 20 times a day on
twitter it doesn't matter so i'd be
taking clips and the one-liners and
posting that to twitter but at all you
don't have to think about new stuff
all you have to do is do your long-form
content and then the team cuts up all
the pieces takes everything out and now
you're on every single platform just by
doing your regular shows
that's fantastic so certification
students customers is a series and you
can even do them all on one day or or
you know an afternoon once a week or
whatever and your assistant just lines
them up for you
45 minute breaks you know or half an
hour at a time when you line up six
students to go back to back and you're
doing three hours of calls and then you
got content for the next couple months
um that's awesome
then whatever your regular training
videos are too
uh
plus if you if you're able to talk about
anything trending anything in the news
anything that you have an opinion on
even if you don't have to have like a
hard like you're going to piss people
off intentionally but in an educational
way just take that vibe that you said
there's so much good that's happening
that people don't know about
right what are those things and then you
start to be the guy who shares it that
brings you to that which other people
don't have access to because i'm on the
inside i deal with a lot of these yes
that makes sense whatever those things
are in your mind if that could be a
weekly show to say here's what this
here's what's happening here this
company this new coin or whatever you're
going to talk about
um be the guy who's spreading those
things instead of having to spread the
negativity
that's excellent thank you very very
much evan i don't know what your
timeline is for these but uh um it's
been flying for me and i'm really really
value you know i've got a lot of value
this one final question on these are
these at all recorded by any chance is
any of this recorded this is recorded
like instagram lives go to become
recorded so here's my process right so
you're moving makers if people bought
for a year they get a chance to do the
one-on-one with me right so it's a
different like you can even
this wasn't sold but you could sell it
right even as part of your certification
they could
buy one-on-one time with george it also
becomes a video to go on your youtube
channel maybe that's a thousand dollar
plus thing to get the one-on-one time
with you and the content but for me it's
just built in it's free to do an
instagram live this this will be saved
on my instagram afterwards so after when
this is done it'll be there you can
watch it back you know team that's
exactly how i think i'm gonna take notes
from all this but right now i'm holding
my phone in my hand and i didn't even
put on my headset i'm like
yeah it's all good anyway and then we
take the best ones and and we'll convert
it to a youtube video
excellent so that's fantastic moving
from instagram to youtube we just have
to we're on top of each other here we
just gotta rotate it to be side by side
that's cool but i wouldn't even like i
wouldn't recommend it for you just do
zoom
and then post
a little bit of editing go right to
youtube and then cut the clips together
and every platform
youtube and twitter should be your top i
mean discord if you have your own
community like that's where that's where
your people are hanging out you can post
clips post your 45 second clips there's
a new george section george's thoughts
there's a channel in your discord
george's thoughts right george's
what do you eat george's snacks george i
don't know something with a g no you
know i i have a section where i always
say hi stretch level with another
valuable cryptocurrency clip and that's
a little that's typically my little
cryptocurrency clip and uh and i say you
know like i'll tell you something about
what's the difference between a coin and
a token i keep it under under 60 second
and that's a cryptocurrency clip join me
later for more cryptocurrency clips
something like that's what i always say
it's like a little clip something like
that i would do anything i could do all
of that and just cut out the intro extra
oh cool just write it so don't intro
yeah just wait
don't don't even i don't have to say hi
short slide with another valuable
cryptocurrency clip screw that yeah tell
me the tip good yeah
that's awesome
and and you don't even need to now
record these because you can pull the
clips from your videos
in this has been a bunch of aha moments
that my team could pull out and turn
those into me sharing so i don't even
know what i said today i don't know i
said stuff cool those could all be
clipped into different pieces of content
that i can put on different channels
if you have your discord then again
whatever you're posting to twitter the
45 second video that you're posting
everywhere right also be a daily clip
to your discord
that's pulled from the stuff that you've
already talked about yeah and the key
thing like for example right now this
this instagram channel is empty i don't
have anything in there i think i have
one video that i recorded i put in there
and the question is i have a whole stack
of like 60 second or less videos from
before which i believe is under the
reels limit right 60 seconds yeah
and the question is if i have those um
does the platform because i haven't even
tried this afterwards if i have it in my
phone i can upload a video into it i
don't have to record something to put
into instagram live yeah you can
definitely upload
groovy that's awesome or give it to you
like just give access to your team to
upload the content and then they can put
it up for you
cool and that's the final one i'm not
going to waste your time on that one but
the thing is like i'm thinking i have to
do everything through this device in my
hand right like not on my computer or
anything like that which would be
different i'm just so used to using a
computer that's it okay yeah every
platform is pretty even youtube is
pretty easy to upload
from your phone or from your team's
phone
okay groovy yeah awesome all right thank
you let's go george thanks a lot thank
you very much
you did it absolutely thank you so very
much
thank you have a beautiful one thank you
there she is
erica elena in the house how are we
doing doing pretty good a little nervous
i'll be honest i've never done instagram
live before oh my goodness it's
happening eric is doing her first
instagram live this is amazing well what
what a time to do it i mean erica is
part of move for makers and as part of
that we do an instagram live together so
uh you got it all set up it's working
what what um what's what's on your mind
how can i help how can i give some
perspective where are we at
well i am at the very beginning of this
journey of doing things on social media
i mean i've been around forever the gray
hair proves it i've been around for a
while if i have no hair does that mean
i've been around for longer or what
i don't know hey let's let some of it
grow back and let's see if you have any
gifts like this
i love it i love it yeah so i'm really
starting to engage with this and i want
to thank you for that because having the
scheduled and being part of movement
makers is really pulling me out of my
perfectionist shell
that has had me stuck
and i'm a little terrified but i'm going
for it i'm moving
through it i do have some questions so
i've started this journey i've put some
videos on our post on instagram
and
i posted them because i knew that we
would be here today and then i looked at
your instagram live
is there something that happens with
pressure so having this very hard
deadline
enabled me to get things done
however i'm very critical
of what i did and so i looked at what i
did and then i looked at yours and then
i started comparing and
how what is your process or what do you
how do you get your
post to look so engaging with video
that's a simple question that i have and
then when i find my other ones i will
ask you those as well okay great what a
start i love it and listen i love that
you started i mean that the biggest
thing missing is just momentum and and
you've got a huge track record and a
giant heart and
it's just getting the content up so i'm
glad that this session prompted the
pressure to go and actually make the
content so that we're going live like
erica i don't see any content what are
you doing
[Laughter]
so that's great being critical is
amazing
just not being so critical that
nothing happens right like
you need to balance being your own worst
critic with also your biggest
cheerleader so you know the fact that
you did it is like
let's go we're doing it we're making
content you here on instagram live it's
amazing um in looking at the videos a
couple things come to mind the first is
your um well the website doesn't work so
that's a good starting point which one
so if you go to your instagram bio
uh i'm like oh
d-lane
and you click on the link it it doesn't
work so that's um that's a good starting
point
whether that's you or your your tech
people or whoever
well it's probably me but i don't even
remember what link i have in the bio i
forgot all about the bio
i've had instagram forever
okay but until yesterday i hadn't posted
since covid started so this is how we
gain customers right i mean the idea is
people watch your content and then they
want they click who is this person all
about i've never seen her before and
then they click on your website to learn
more and we want to lead them to
you know a page that works so for now it
goes to
talentinspired.net so
if that is still the website or no not
like so oh it's advertised
but we could change it so that's great
you know we can change that whenever we
want so that that's a good step one
because that's on that's honestly like
if anybody does like you and they watch
the videos like oh that's interesting
that's their next step is okay what's
her website right um so yeah that's an
easy fix for the videos themselves and i
took a you know quick peek i haven't
watched all of them the the biggest
thing that i would focus on for you is
what is the
powerful opinion that you have
on a topic
and and i don't know we've talked about
this before but like what do you believe
that other people don't believe and then
that being the first thing if you talk
about making engaging content especially
in an instagram environment the first 10
seconds
it becomes everything
you know you're trying to stop the
scroll
so people are scrolling through and then
oh you pop up i've never seen you before
and if you don't see something like in
the first 10 seconds first five seconds
i'm just scrolling i'm going to the next
thing
so
some of your posts you're kind of
hedging at the beginning
and so you're saying things like well i
don't know about you but for me
that and then they're gone
[Laughter]
what do you believe that other people
don't believe that
can be the first sentence out of your
mouth because you have a lot of
experience and you have a lot of
opinions and you have a lot of knowledge
that can actually help a lot of people
but if if it takes
like 20 seconds to get out then
it's not going to be as engaging
i wouldn't over stress about
that yet
but that's the next step like the first
step is you did it you posted five
videos that's amazing this is great now
in our next five videos that could be
the fifth thing that we focus on is the
very first sentence is something that's
going to be
something that will make people want to
watch the rest of the video like what
did you just say
huh that's interesting and they want to
keep watching
okay i can i can definitely do that
maybe i'll just go five videos at a time
that that'll be my
be my way to go as we just mentioned
there's five videos that i i did and i
started to feel bad because even though
i haven't posted since
the beginning of covet
i was thinking are people getting
bombarded with every single post that
i'm
that because i did them right after
another
is that what sort of frequency would you
recommend as i get things going yeah so
uh people are not getting bombarded by
your posts you know like the algorithms
especially right now
you know like and we're honestly not
we're not that important you know
i could ask that question on youtube as
well it's like how often is like am i
bombarding people like the average
person subscribed to like hundreds of
different channels
you're not that important you know so
use it as a that's a good thing um what
i would say though is if you're gonna
make five batching the content is great
five at a time is great because
especially at the beginning
it can be a little nerve-wracking you
gotta set up the camera you gotta you
gotta get it together you know just
emotionally and be ready to be in
presenter mode and the time it takes to
to do one video you can then usually do
four videos right afterwards because
you're already in the same energy and
the same lighting and all that stuff
right so just easier to batch them
together then i would release them
one a day
okay so if you're gonna be doing five
you know wednesday afternoon you're
gonna make videos
wink wink you know it's wednesday
afternoon
yeah
let's go erica but you know whenever in
your calendar makes sense
and then you release them
one a day or one every two days
so that they they're they're dripping
out so it's not all five at a time it's
less about bombarding people and more
about
the
instagram just won't show them as much
if you put five out all at the same time
and that's usually the same for every
platform youtube tic toc whatever
if you have five videos you release them
over time got it
well um
to go to something not quite so focused
on instagram posting a question i have
is
i have i have three audiences that i
really can serve with what i do
i have organizational leaders i have
frontline leaders and i have
entrepreneurs
how
do i
serve them all how can i serve them all
i don't know if it's possible i don't
know if i need to have different
channels i'm a little confused about
that because i can i successfully market
to them now
but it's more one-to-one i network i get
a lot of referrals
but doing it through social media is
something
new for me what what are your thoughts
on that the common theme is still
leadership so the common theme is
leadership yeah so you're talking about
leadership so entrepreneurs are a weird
bunch in that
leadership content actually doesn't do
very well
for most entrepreneurs because most
entrepreneurs
are solo entrepreneurs like most
entrepreneurs don't have a leadership
problem they may have a self leadership
problem because they don't know how to
like stick to a schedule and get up and
go do the work and
and
stay consistent so that's more self
leadership but
any time i make content around
leadership or or hr or hiring or
managing it just doesn't do well because
most entrepreneurs aren't in that
position where they even have anybody on
their team and so they're not thinking
about those kinds of problems
and that's fine like those entrepreneurs
aren't the ones that are hiring you yeah
to help them because they can't if they
can't afford to have even a part-time
employee on their staff they're not
hiring you to come and help them right
so it's fine so we're we're not really
it's like a higher level entrepreneur or
maybe business owner that has
x number of employees like at what point
does somebody come in
how big a company do they have to have
or when you start working with the
entrepreneurs typically around 25
employees so i don't know what
percentage of entre you know like
american businesses have
it's it's a small small small number
yeah most people never get 25 employees
so it's it's entrepreneurs but really
it's it's it's business owners
you know like the people who already
have so you're talking to those people
your goal is not to have a million
subscribers or a million followers
your goals have the right followers and
the right subscribers the people who
care about leadership content
now the the you know if there's a
business owner that has 50 employees
and
or there's a manager at a at a
corporation that might be responsible
for 50 people underneath them it's
similar content
you know the problems they're facing are
similar they may have different
levels of what they can control right
like the entrepreneur owner can do
whatever they want they can implement a
new policy as soon as they want a
manager
at
facebook has a hard time because there's
layers of bureaucracy above them
but a lot of the leadership struggles
and challenges will be
similar and so that's
who we're talking to so all the even
though you might have like three
different audiences it's still the main
theme of leadership
and
we want you to be known as the
leadership person
all right that gives me something to
think about when you mentioned that my
audience may not be as large as others i
think that is something to be
for me to be very aware of and it's uh i
think that's going to be a big takeaway
for me
um
because i think when i think of social
media i'm thinking
it's got to be this huge following where
in my case it may not make sense and
there's something i need to be okay with
something to accept
so i i appreciate that thank you well
it's like what are your what are your
goals you know what are your ambitions
do you want to be
do you want to be an influencer and have
a million followers or do you want to
grow your leadership practice
and
and you tell me because if you want to
be
the face for america for something then
we have to go way downstream and talk to
more startups
and and wannabes and considering
people who will never hire you but
they're at the very beginning because
most people are at step zero like
they're just getting started i think
that's something i've been kind of
struggling with and
in terms of who should i serve so right
now as i mentioned got the people that
have a minimum of 25 employees up to 10
000 employees
and they're already a clientele for that
group it's all it's been a matter of me
to continue to establish some sort of
thought leadership
however
what i
get excited about and passionate about
is helping people that are at the
beginning that want to build something
bigger than what they are so it's not
necessarily the person starting a
business to
to
be a solopreneur
i'm interested in helping those
individuals that are are building
something bigger how big it is who knows
but those individuals that will need to
think about culture one day those
individuals that when they are hiring
their
first second third fourth fifth employee
they know how to do that in such a way
that there is
um integrity within
their within their structure to help
them learn how to stretch and grow and
in many ways get out of their own way
because that's what happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs we get in our own way and
so things just don't grow
and
i have because i've worked with
companies that have these are small
companies 20
in the grand scheme of things 25
employees if you compare that to a
company that has 10 10 000
you know those are some smaller
companies i work with but they had to go
through some changes they had some
growth to get to that point so i want to
work with those i'm excited to work with
those people that are at the beginning
a fantasy of mine would be to be
connected with the different incubators
all around the world startups
and connecting and talking to them more
about
this beginning piece helping them truly
understand themselves
deeply and better because things are
going to grow from
from there so i would think of it as
three different buckets and there's
different size of buckets and
there's no right or wrong it's really
more like what what's the right for you
that you want to go and chase down right
so the the smallest
size bucket with the highest revenue
bucket immediately is is the people who
you're already serving right like 25
employees to 10 000 employees you
already have a business model that works
they will pay you you you make a lot of
money doing it they're ideal clients
making content on social for people who
are searching
that's like you make one deal
from that that ends up paying for
everything right it just that's a
no-brainer kind of starting point
that's the
big big revenue bucket immediate
business model but super small clientele
the next stage would be the people who
are at the beginning of their hiring
journey and they're starting to think
about hiring and culture and training
and leadership and it's like just
starting to come on their radar
whether that's through videos whether
that's through incubators whether that's
like they're they're going and they're
searching how do i be a better boss you
know like they hired somebody like
everybody goes to that they hire
somebody he's like this person's gonna
solve all my problems and then that
person quits because you don't know how
to lead them and then you're back to
writing like maybe i'll just do it all
myself instead like all of those
problems and starting up right
so then it's like what's the business
model that's going to be attached to it
and maybe we don't care maybe you're
just building a brand maybe you're just
trying to get the message out there i'm
always concerned that i want to make
sure that you're making not just you but
anybody like you're making money in the
process so that it's not just this hobby
on the side so your priority for this
year is like i want this to generate
revenue for me then we're targeting 25
employee plus people we know we have a
business model for
if it's i'm building my brand and i'm
going to do something at scale i'm going
to do group coaching i'm going to i'm
going to have my book or my course or i
want to i want to be a speaker or like
we're building the erica brand
then
the payoff revenue wise is longer
because it's nothing direct right now
but we're building towards something
that is exciting for you that for the
next five years that decade we're going
to be building right
cool that's that's like the the and that
that leads to tons of opportunities like
maybe you get maybe you get asked to
join the board of some of these
incubators and you're taking a piece of
every company that goes like there's so
many opportunities that then open
themselves up to you and it it can
create a
a longer term bigger model than just
time for for money as a consultant right
yes i definitely want to step out of the
time for money business model and it's
great to have like both
so you you're making money doing your
service cool and you're building this
thing because if if you stop being a
consultant then you have no money coming
in
it's like well that's a problem right so
doing both is great the third bucket is
the biggest bucket which then is self
leadership
which i don't know if you even want to
dive into or not
because that's where most people are at
they're not thinking culture and
teamwork and leadership and like that's
not even on the radar for most people
but self-leadership definitely is
and so if you wanted to be like broad
that's where you go after you can have a
million subscriber channel and and try
to go big
um and that could still lead to book
deals and courses and speaking and board
seats and everything else it's just more
of a personal choice like how much of
your
passion connects to self leadership
versus
leading teams of people
well you you say that and one of the
stories i think about um
is when my daughter was a little girl we
were in church this it feels like a
gazillion years ago
and
i
i was just sitting there
i was just sitting just sitting there on
the church pew probably trying to stay
awake who knows what i was trying to do
and i finally just sit up i straighten
up and then out of the corner of my eye
i noticed my daughter she she did the
same thing
and so the con the the idea that someone
is always watching more leading by
example has something that's always
fascinated me and that could connect to
self leadership
um
yeah that i mean that's a dep that's a
definite possibility i don't think i've
ever thought of it
i don't think i've ever thought of
self-leadership as a topic that i would
speak on because typically i'm working
with people that are trying to move up
in their career they're trying to get a
promotion or maybe there's some sort of
remediation
but there is always that connection
between
their job their life
i don't know that's something that's
something i have to think about that
third bucket that's something brand new
you're already doing it you may not have
been you may not have been like calling
it that but like if somebody then if
you're coaching somebody you give them
advice on what they need to do they
still need to go off and and do it and
they need to stay consistent on their
calendar and that's like how does
somebody then
execute the advice that you give them
well that's self leadership
right where how many times that people
say they're gonna do something or go to
a conference and get excited and then
not follow through right so like they
have poor self-leadership and so whether
we want to call it like motivation or
habits or belief systems or whatever at
the end of the day it's leading yourself
to go do the thing
and the more you are a role model for
yourself you become a role model for
other people you know from sitting up
straight into church to anything to when
you show up at the office
first first and leave a lot you know or
you're the last person to leave all that
um
and so that that's definitely a model
but it's more like that's a hard
decision do you
want to be that woman
or it's like no i like culture teamwork
and and my dream is to help incubators
and people who are at the starting stage
of hiring but i don't want to dive into
the personal stuff
yeah that's uh like you said it's a
heart thing and so i am i think i'm
going to have to go in and just kind of
marinate in that and
make it
through yeah just get in there and
marinate in it and then we'll put put on
the barbecue
so so then from the content right so
it's still it's all leadership content
so it's
it's the the content for the
organizations and like leading a team of
people
it's a content and leadership of of
getting started and the first things you
need to consider and then potentially
it's like like the one and two you
definitely want to do so we already know
that the third bucket is a maybe and so
if it becomes a yes and you want to tell
stories that then can bring
even your story there with with your
daughter that's more but that's like
parenting but that's still leadership
well yeah that's true
but it's still leadership it's all
leadership right so it's like how much
do we want to expand the scope of
leadership because when you do that and
you see that in your daughter you then
take that to your business and your
career and say maybe i can if i could do
that with my daughter maybe i can
influence the people at the board room
table here and i'm going to
set up straight or i'm going to have
more energy i'm going to smile more it
all connects it's still all leadership
just how much do you want to play in
that third field or not
yeah well i mean you say that
and i i think
about a time where i was actually
speaking on something i call maternal
leadership the the leadership that
mothers
have
and so i've always gravitated towards
leadership and maternal leadership has
nothing to do with
a big organization or
a career per se like outside of the home
but it embodies all of life and how do
you make it work and so lots to think
about this is
well that's good it's good we're
marinating you're going to marinate on
it we're marinating i'm like
here's the recommendation then like we
know we want to plane one and two and
three is probably something that you'll
want to get into which is the how
exactly is still
got to figure out but if you're going to
make five videos
every every kind of filming day then you
can do two towards the large companies
two towards the startups and one
one fun one towards
churches or motherhood or
self-leadership or
whatever is kind of
whatever comes from the marination
yeah whatever maybe i'll just call it
marinade this is the marinated bucket
but it's still all leadership right like
it's still all leadership and that's the
connective tissue and all of the
all of the stories that you share in the
examples you give will have ripple
effects out to that person's entire life
beyond just this one scenario that we're
solving
i agree i agree
okay and it'll get uh
the first bucket you have the most
knowledge and most depth and most like
bang on you'll be the most perfect
because you know that inside out the
second one you're exploring and having
fun with and you've helped a lot of
startups and maybe not as many as like
the corporations and the third one is
the least clear and most
fuzzy foggy whatever and so the content
will be
it's the work in progress it's like
letting go of the perfection of if i'm
making a video on motherhood leadership
it may not be as good out of the gate as
the one
talking about higher how to hire
somebody and like what questions should
you ask in in you know a job interview
or like the stuff that you'll know how
to do inside out versus
the motherhood one where you may have to
think a lot more because you're working
through it
yeah okay
this is this is good i see that our time
is up that went so fast
time flies when you're having fun
yeah well i'll see you tomorrow in mover
makers
and and uh marinate on those and and
then let me know how how it's sitting i
think there's i think it's definitely
something there and it's great to have
that mix of
i actually know what i'm talking about
here and i'm exploring and playing in
these other areas as well i think it'll
be okay you have an impact on people and
also will be it'll be fun
it'll be fun all right to see me coach
another entrepreneur one-on-one check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there all of these ideas
can work
there's no rules and ig's a day or is
not a lot of time like 45 seconds not
not edited just go and film it that's
way easier than producing a podcast or
going up and do men in the street